he sold 75 million records worldwide
which makes him one of the best-selling
recording artists of all time
billboard named him the second most
successful artist of the 2000s decade he
owns the record label Raymond Braun
Media Group
he's Usher and here's my take on his top
10 rows a success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one have passion what's the
secret to your success like what what
are you doing that makes us care so much
about you what's the secret to Usher
it's that family man it's that
irreplaceable feeling of real music and
entertainment I feel very fortunate
because I've had a lot of people around
to help build what it is but to be able
to perform the record to be able to sell
a record through performance dance
vocally and the passion of what it is I
think that that's what continues to keep
people connected to Who I am as an
artist and that RB music allows you to
feel or my music I don't know if it's
our viewer if it's just music period the
music that I create and that I've lived
through and experiences that I've been
able to you know borrow from to create
inspiration for our songs that we create
together mm-hmm
you know they're real experiences that
people can feel that that's an
irreplaceable feeling and soulful music
something you could feel yeah something
you can feel rule number two find your
path but I knew what I wanted to do from
the age of like 11 so when I figured it
out and I had a path like felt like it
was getting ready to go away I was like
I don't want to lose this if I do I'm
gonna I'm gonna die if I don't have
music if I don't have my entertainment
it's over it's over for me
so that was one of my most interesting
at 16 you were already nervous about it
going away dude at 13 I was like I'm out
like I'm figuring this out I'm gone I
got it I want to entertain I want to be
an artist my mother was like you're not
gonna be one of those people who's just
sitting around and sleeping on my couch
don't worry about I'll be gone by 14 if
you can if you can see it in your mind
and it can happen cuz what's out here
ain't gonna assist you in that way you
got to find it
rule number three evolve sure we all
have to set goals for ourselves I mean
our planting destination is to be busy
and to you know adjust to whatever you
whatever you're introduced to and what I
mean by that is okay as an entertainer I
started off as a singer you know I grew
to become a dancer and a performer
after becoming a performer then I became
an actor after becoming an actor I
became an entrepreneur after become an
entrepreneur I became an entertainer on
a different level of introducing other
artists then you know after that I
became a mentor you know so I think just
to continue to evolve in a way that is
beneficial for growth of myself and
others my likeness to continue to be
remembered throughout history and
associated with something great for me
you know there's a there's a mantra that
I've I've lived by and it is that the
journey of the destination is really
what it's all about the pursuit is more
important than the actual destination so
as long as you are moving as long as
you're working that is the destination
Wow yeah the journey but really it is
simply that the journey is the
destination I agree as long as you're
working you're you're good well number
four love I think that all artists of
the past having gone through what
they've gone through or the scrutiny
that they go through it was don't become
calloused part I think that that was
what he was attempting to say remember
you gotta love you got to find love as
the key to get through so many people
coming at you with the negative because
you can't allow what they feel about you
to turn you into who they see or want
you to be also if you want to have more
videos profile on leaders in the black
community check out my 254 block
excellent series it's free the link to
join is in the description below
it's that irreplaceable feeling of real
music and entertainment rule number five
believe in yourself
and I can remember at the age of nine
years old saying you know why I want to
do that you know I want to do I want to
be like Michael Jackson I want to be
like you know no addition I want to be
like Bobby Brown I want to do what they
do you know where you got to work at it
you know of course I went through talent
shows and there was no American Idol
back here you know there was no European
on vitals back in that day which would
be perfect you know that was Star Search
actually I did Star Search believe it or
not which was an Ed McMahon production
in our Orlando Florida it was the you
know the the category comparison to what
I think American Idol is in this day in
time but not many opportunities so I had
to believe in myself and luckily I had a
mother that you know helped me to
develop and I was there with me you know
the hand of the business side because I
couldn't do both but now as I grown
older I've now even taken more control
of that and you know our building
outside of what I just doing music you
know building brands
I now AM an owner of a basketball team
the Cleveland Cavaliers and America and
I think it's great to be determined I
think that's what I'll tell them and to
you know have great worth ethics you
know you got to work at it if you want
to be great at it period and you know be
benevolent in your approach you have to
you know want it and take no for you you
will never you would never take no for
an answer I can do it no I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna be good at what I do and never
let anybody tell you you can't well
number six learn from your failures and
pre share with people who you know
headed out
[Music]
as I said you know artists objected some
people have an opinion they like about
it and of course they have their title
too because they're paying their money
for it
but you know I never let that stop me
I've always been able to turn my head
into great and not really accept any
down moments low peaks as a failure but
yet a lesson to teach me how to be
better stronger more wise and resilient
you know I really have never gotten to
the negative stuff I just I don't really
absorb it rule number seven pursue your
dreams I just continue to grow and do
more I mean that that's what being a
career artist is it's really about you
know um and I created a template of what
I wanted to do as a young man and
continue to pursue you know my dreams
and be inspired by people who did great
things you know the great developers
great people who you know found musical
cultural movements and wanted to
introduce them artists who were very
fashionable and fashiona for it in their
process all of that is Who I am being a
businessman you know being an actor
being a writer being a producer being a
songwriter being a fan I have to piss
all of those things and as long as
there's something they do I'm really
doing it when you were growing up did
you always think that this would be
where you were gonna end up no I didn't
actually I only had the dream and
supported the people who encouraged me
to believe in myself and my dreams
and without them I probably would not be
Who I am
had I not been you know introduced to
the right things the right time I mean I
do feel like there is no such thing as a
coincidence I do feel like things are
destined to happen ordained to happen
and as a result of hard work there's a
reward so you put all that together and
you know
you have a success story but no as a kid
I didn't see oh I did see half of what I
what I'm saying nowadays but I knew that
I wanted to do something in music and I
knew that I wanted to travel the world
and hear you act rule number eight
surprised people consistently
inconsistent you know and at the end of
the day it's about being in the moment
you know
I mean 20 if you just listen to all
those records I mean just let those
records run in the audience that made
them number one and they're gonna enjoy
it so I want to give them a bit of a new
experience yeah I don't know if I said
it that way
then because I was still working on it
that's the truth so now that I've gotten
closer and I'm getting closer to this
three-year anticipation of returning to
the stage to do a tour yeah you know
just I've been looking at all of the
shows that I did in the past and
listening to all of the records and
finding the the thread that pulls them
all together and then mixing and
matching them you know it's in and for
me it's a it's a it's kind of like I'm
gonna give you the show that you would
have expected to see but then throw in a
few surprises here and there that you
didn't expect I've done duets yeah
there's a lot of people that I respect
and then I built with two that you do
know about DJ Cassidy in August Alsina
they'll be on the show but there's a few
surprises that happens from market to
market it's never consistent it changes
up every night
me of course there are certain songs
that will consistently be in a certain
spot but you won't be able to hashtag
you art or I mean hashtag urx tour and
see the show yeah you have to be there
every night is its own experience so
market the market if you get the chance
to be at this show it's gonna be one of
the nights that you remember not only
because of the records that I've I have
for you but also to a few of you know
the surprises that I got for you
rule number nine me history losing
Michael was difficult but usher finds
comfort in the memories and the lessons
he learned from the King of Pop
when you were there for the memorial
service in Los Angeles what was it like
for you that day
aside from it being the greatest honor
that I could pay to the artist and the
man that made me who I am it's almost so
unrealistic like did it really happen is
Michael really gone
one thing that Michael told me one very
tender moment that we had together he
said what you do and what you're capable
of doing is not easy and not all not
everybody can do it you know be mindful
of history because it's never just a
moment
it's about making history
and making music as he says he's back
and with all his success pusher says
this is just the beginning of history
and rule number ten the last Samba for a
very special bonus clip is be a role
model the same way I needed a mentor the
same way I needed someone to motivate me
that became our reality I want to be
that source for merry I want to be that
source for dewy I want to be that source
for men and women who feel like no one
can hear or understand them and how they
need is the tools to understand how to
be great or either apply themselves you
know I started that effort when I was 16
with the idea that the most influential
role model for a child is a child if I
come into your school when I talk to you
about what I could do that's a point of
reference you know the community
television in a lot of ways social media
it doesn't show positive images every
every second as a matter of fact we
don't celebrate those images as much as
we celebrate bullish you know well we
did actually get to visit an elementary
school where we got to see uh sure hang
out with the kids for a while because of
the language barrier he needed a little
help while speaking to them but once
they warmed up to each other Spanish
versus English didn't really matter
as their substitute teacher for the day
that was my opportunity to let them know
this and you can loosen up a little bit
I want you to make as much noise as you
possibly can
it was just allowing them to have fun
you know I think that their teachers
their counselors their principal you
know told them that you know they should
be on their best behavior and I think
that's great that's appropriate but so
also to be free to be kids to be
expressive is why I'm there
it's why I came is why I'm adopting the
school that's why I feel like making a
contribution by way of supplies tools
and the means to be creative and be
expressive that's why I'm there so to
let them know hey listen from jump
I'm not your teachers I'm actually one
of you and we can actually have a great
time together I know you can't
understand everything I'm saying but
let's have fun and and understand the
education at that age when they hear an
adult or a person who's the celebrity
tell them that an education is the most
important thing to get it's the truth
it's part of the reason that I've gone
as far as I have and you know at six and
seven they should be able to have a good
time and it not be so damn serious
[Applause]
now I've got a such a bonus kit from uh
sure on how to work hard that I think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one
how will you be a good role model for
your community number two how will you
surprise someone today and number three
what failure from your past will you
learn from an aspiring actor singer
dancer what advice would you give them
mmm they want to make it you want to
make it then don't do it for the glory
of it do it for the passion of it
because it's not guarantee that it will
happen of course you can be positive and
you should be positive but at the same
time it didn't happen overnight
you know there are special cases and
people who have incredible talent and
even those people have to be nurtured by
the right people you know step fast and
I guess my greatest bit of advice is
work hard be a student
if you want to see the top 10 I did on
Chris Brown checking the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there we can never say business is his
business because if you passionate about
everything is personal my only
competition is to be myself make sure
you got a lot of loyalty right